Tired of the frustrations of politics
and policy, school reformers have taken to
turning to the courts to drive real
reform. The most famous example of this is
the Vergara lawsuit in California, in
which the judge ruled that California's
tenure laws violated the right of
students to get an effective education. A
lot to sympathize with in that ruling,
even if it was later overturned by the
state Supreme Court. Couple problems
though with turning to the courts: First,
the reality is if a judge can say
you can't have teacher tenure, it's not
clear what else judges can throw out.
Can they say no charter schools? No
school vouchers? It's a real risk. Second,
courts are no panacea. The state of New
Jersey has been in a long-running
lawsuit for a half century, in which the
Abbott school districts have gotten
billions in extra aid and still aren't
serving kids well. I'm a big fan of
changing schools in a way that serves kids,
but I think the most promising route
lies through the hard work of politics
and policy, and not the pleasing
shortcuts offered by the courts.
To learn more about my take on school reform,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.